the tougher they were the better I got
along with them and that's probably a
good thing because it was a tough ones
that had the big powerful countries the
ones that can do destruction yeah this
is so much simpler this is so much
simpler for whatever reason you want to
say it is and you could say it's because
of Trump's relationship with his father
you could psychoanalyze you could you
could come up with 20 different reasons
as to why Trump is enamored with these
authoritarian strong men and sometimes
they are genocidal dictators he's
enamored with them Trump's not impressed
with diplomats like Angela Merkel or
Justin Trudeau Emmanuel macron he's he's
not it's not impressive and in fact
Trump's relationships with our
historical Western allies were
significantly uh damaged while he was
president and the U.S was increasingly
not even a part of many important
discussions with our historical allies
while Trump was President Trump was
enamored with the dictators